14. it's going to be a Hot Weekend by
the way and just in time Clark County is
opening a new place to cool off yes the
Southeast Valley is the Whitney Water
Park Grand Opening is tomorrow our
Candace Charles is there it's on
Missouri near Boulder Highway between
trop and Russell Kansas you keep teasing
us you're going to get in the water
there
You Gotta Wait Nate almost almost no
it's a little bit cold right now even
though the water is actually really nice
and warm this water park has been a long
time coming been talked about for about
four years it took about a year to get
it done 12 million dollars put into this
park and have Recreation specialist
Justin Gilbert here with me tell me a
little bit more about the park here so
we've added in a classroom here that you
can actually rent out so if you have a
birthday party or any big event you can
rent that space out have your own little
area with air conditioning a TV tables
you can set it up decorate it it's got a
sink involved too we have these two nice
new water slides you have to be 48
inches tall to ride them I think I can
make that happen oh yeah I think you're
just barely tall enough we have all
these nice plate features here they've
copied a lot of stuff and kind of made
it a combination of Desert Breeze and
Hollywood their outdoor water parks we
have a volleyball net here that'll be
set up a lazy river and a lot of other
fun cool stuff absolutely and it's all
opening up and kicking off this Saturday
from noon to four tell us a little bit
about the grand opening here there's
gonna be a lot of free stuff yes there's
going to be a live band there's going to
be free tacos free gelato and a bunch of
other little giveaways that we're going
to be doing uh each half hour-ish we're
doing a game that'll have a bunch of
prize bags for kids to get we're giving
out 100 free life jackets to the first
hundred people while supplies last so
there's a lot of free stuff that you can
get absolutely definitely it sounds like
it's gonna be a great time thank you so
much for joining us this morning you
guys I got you covered with all the
details on our website of course
8newsnow.com again it all kicks off
tomorrow May 13th from noon to 4. you
can register online but you can also
just come on down here and you guys can
get it in of course Nick has already
mentioned it I will be getting in the
pool and the only way I'm gonna get in
the pool is on this big boy right here
coming up I'll tell you a little bit
about the slide features here how long
they are and of course you guys get to
see me make it a little wet but for now
live at the windy water park I'm Candace
Charles it is now a squeal or will you
be squealing on the way down too
I'm scared already
echoing to the East Valley what's that
sound yeah
thanks Candace